hi guys so I know I don't usually post
these types of non edited vlog style
type videos on my main channel but I've
been lacking so bad because these past
two weeks have been so crazy that my
video content on this channel well there
really hasn't been much other than
but enough about that I just want to
thank you guys for subscribing and
always being so supportive and also
watching my crazy random videos that I
post on my other YouTube channel got a
haircut today but then I took a nap on
it so this is what happened because some
of those are just insane yeah yeah and
you guys still watch and comment and we
give me lots of Internet YouTube love
there so anyway these past two weeks
have been crazy my sister's were in town
and they helped me move to a new
apartment wait let me get this let me
get this for you Oh
me in the face I'm not I'm gonna soar my
leg no bigger that's not gonna work I'm
sorry dad cut you are way
by another green-screen they made me go
on prices right we went to Vegas we went
all these crazy places I've never heard
a rabid raccoon birth before but hello
people I'm not here in station they
can't see you dancing the reason that we
were here at this event is this vending
machine right here walking persons right
I definitely did more in the past two
weeks than I did the past few years that
I've been spending time in LA anyway it
was a lot of fun I also became extremely
addicted to playing Mario Galaxy and now
I'm really sad because playing it by
myself is not as much fun as playing
with my sister we got pretty good have
you played this game of you beat it if
you have given me some pointers
because let me tell you the Penguins
surf level it was pretty rough for me
but anyway I just wanted to say hi and
thank you guys again for being so
supportive and I promise there will be
an ask IJ episode here sometime soon so
feel free to leave your questions and if
you want out of 80 response here for a
future ask IG episode feel free to do
that
ah that's all I got I just wanna say hi
and give you a quick update so you know
that I am still alive
hello I am still living
I haven't yet completely unpacked my new
apartment but I'm working on it
so alright I will see you guys in the
next video that I post here or on my
other channel and I'll see you guys on
Twitter
you